So for educational purposes,
here is how I process a chicken at home.
This chicken just came out the plucker.
It's freshly unalived and I'm gonna start processing.
The first thing I'm doing is gonna take the legs off.
I'm gonna let the knife do most of the work here.
I did put a little bit of pressure on this one
as some of them are a little bit stiffer than others.
Then I'm gonna head and remove the skin.
I did dip the chicken in 150 degree water
and this helps to remove the feathers and the skin.
Gonna use the feet for some broth,
so I wanna make sure the skin is removed.
Then I'm gonna remove the crop.
This bits kinda slimy and hard to grab hold of.
This is why we make sure the chickens don't eat
a few days before we process.
We don't want this full of food.
This kinda acts like a chicken's stomach.
This is where food goes to ferment
before it passes on down to the rest of the digestive tract.
Then I'm gonna give this a firm pour
and it's gonna release from the internal organs
and then I'm just gonna snip it.
Then I'm gonna finish removing the rest of the neck.
I'm gonna use these necks for chicken broth.
We don't waste them. The dogs actually like them as treats,
but we're gonna use them as broth.
Then I'm gonna remove the tail and then make an incision.
And move away from myself and not poke inside the organs.
Do not want to make any lacerations to the internal organs.
And with a firm hand,
I'm gonna remove all the internal organs and cut away the butthole.
I'm very careful to do this.
I do not wanna make any lacerations into the digestive tract.
Now, once I did that,
I did grab hold of the lungs and rip those out.
It's not necessary to remove the lungs.
And this is the heart.
This one had a healthier looking heart.
Some of them have been covered in fat,
as these meat birds are definitely ready to be processed.
Here we have the kidney, spleen,
liver, and we have the gizzards right here.
And this chicken was a girl.
So this is the ovary that's producing the eggs.
And the eggs were still starting to form.
This is a young chicken, so she didn't lay any eggs yet.
Then I'm gonna rinse off the third and package it,
put it in the freezer, and it'll be ready to eat.